we're not trying to make everything half
Jewish and half Japanese I'm easy to
call it Jewish Japanese but it's more
than that it comes from a very like
genuine place I think our food is a lot
about building bridges not about
barriers between cultures my name is
Sawako Oh coach I'm a chef/owner of
shallow Japan my name is Erin Israel and
I'm also a chef and owner of she love
Japan so we've been together for years
years
Shalom Japan is our restaurant the food
is a collaboration between the two of us
I grew up in Oshima and I lived in New
York to go to a corner school I grew up
in Great Neck New York which is Jewish
we grew the restaurant organically out
of being dating and then living together
and sharing different foods but I really
wanted to open my own restaurant and so
I think we just decided at one point
we're like hey let's just do it together
Janome Japan has been open for six years
one of the first dishes that we put on
the menu is a lockable our locks bowl is
our version of chirashi which is a
Japanese dish of raw fish over sushi
rice we put our house cured locks over
sushi rice and then we put a whole bunch
of traditional Japanese ingredients and
also some Jewish ingredients of Japanese
pickles fried capers avocado and
cilantro our matzo ball ramen is our
version of a very classic Jewish soup
and then has the ramen noodles matzo
ball has a little gilze that we filled
with chicken and foie gras yeah look
garlic chili oil grandma I didn't put
garlic chili oil and the matzo ball soup
in my house Saki a casa challah is
hollow as a traditional Jewish bread
almost like a brioche and we bake sake
Kazu into it it's like custard is the
leftover mash when you make sake so it
kind of eesti kind of fermented kind of
kind of a little funky our food seems
like an unlikely combination sort of who
we are it's what we cook at home the
experiences that we've had together how
we kind of take those and then express
them at our restaurant I hear that
people are presently supplies because
people come in was like what is this
place funny name Shalom Japan and they
have changed their mind that by being in
the meal that you know I was delicious
never had anything like this you know
that that's the response we get a lot
and that's what gets us going
I think our food is not about putting up
barriers between cultures but looking at
how can we relate to each other like
through those
[Music]